[MUSIC PLAYING]
ACE NASSRI: So
hi, my name's Ace.
I'm a developer programs
engineer here at Google Cloud.
And today, we're
going to be talking
about releasing with
confidence-- so testing,
debugging, and monitoring
in a serverless world.
So our agenda for today--
first off, we're going
to talk about testing,
what it is, how we
do it, why we do it,
just kind of as an
explanation of the context
of this presentation.
Then, we're going to
take that knowledge
and wrap it up in the world
of functions as a service.
Third, we're going
to talk about how
to automate this
process using CI/CD,
or continuous integration
and deployment platforms.
And fourth, we're going
to talk a little bit
about the operations
of functions.
So first, a quick
background on testing.
Testing can be defined as
sort of two separate things.
So we're asking two
high-level questions here.
First of all, does our code
work in the first place?
And second of all, does
our code work well?
So lower-level questions we can
ask under this heading include,
but are not limited
to, does our code
work with style and
language guidelines?
Does our code work with
its latest dependencies?
Does our code work when
subjected to extreme loads?
Or perhaps even,
does our code work
when provided malicious or
otherwise invalid input?
So along this, there's
a broad spectrum
of tests we can
rely on to help us
answer the question of whether
or not our code works at all.
So off to the
left, you'll notice
we have unit tests,
which, generally speaking,
are faster and more specific.
Off to the right, we
have system tests,
which are slower and
more comprehensive.
And then in the middle,
we have integration tests,
which are kind of a
hybrid of the two.
So generally speaking, the
goal of this presentation
is to get you to
a point where you
can figure out whether or
not your code works at all.
We are less concerned
about figuring out
why it does not work,
although that is
something I will get to later.
So along those
lines, system tests
are typically more essential
for determining whether or not
your code works at all.
Now, unit tests can be
helpful when it comes time
to determine why your code
doesn't work because they give
you greater granularity
of what the failures are
and what things are going wrong.
So as a rough indication of
how many types of each test
you need, on the bottom of the
slide we have a rough diagram.
So imagine that
you have a feature.
And this feature is
tested by one system test.
So if you were to cover
that feature completely
with integration tests, you
might need two integration
tests, or perhaps even
up to four unit tests
to cover that
feature completely.
Note that these
ratios are not exact,
they are simply an example.
So the second high-level
aspect of testing
that we can investigate is,
not only does our code work,
but does it work well?
So static tests
are a type of test
that tests your code
for things such as style
without actually
running the code.
All the other tests we
will talk about today
involve actually running
a part of your code.
So load testing, this
is a type of system test
that directly measures
your code's ability
to handle either expected
or unexpected loads.
Basically, you throw a
bunch of traffic at it
and see if it can
handle the punishment.
And then, fuzz tests and
vulnerability scanners
test your code's ability
to handle malicious input,
so if people try to
hack your application
or things like that.
So as far as why we test--
so testing can be thought
of as an insurance
policy against potential bugs
and their associated business
impact.
So if you ever need to
justify to management, well,
why should we write tests?
It's not so much,
they prevent bugs,
as much as it is,
they prevent bugs
which might have a business
impact on our bottom line.
So the first goal of
testing is to reduce
the likelihood of
software errors happening
in the first place.
The second is to
verify code correctness
on an ongoing basis.
If you wanted to manually
test your code once or twice,
that's easy enough to do.
The problem comes when
you want to test it, say,
every week or every day.
After a while, the
cost spent manually
testing is greater than the cost
of just automating it and then
running an automated test suite
each time you want to test it.
So the stretch goal here
is to quickly identify
the errors caught by
any test that we have.
It's not strictly
necessary, but it
would be helpful in
the debugging process.
So as far as the
impact of testing,
Google's OSS-Fuzz
fuzzing project
found more than 250 potential
security vulnerabilities
in major open source software
within its first five
months of execution.
And inadequate
software testing has
been estimated to cost
the United States up
to 1% of its annual GDP alone.
And here are the
citations for those stats.
So now that we've
talked a little bit
about testing as
a concept, we're
going to move on to applying
that to the world of functions
as a service.
So first off as kind of
a recap about unit tests,
the core idea of a
unit test is to verify
that the minutiae, or the
individual units of your code,
work as expected, so things
like edge case checking.
Now, in a unit test, there is
no reliance on or verification
of external dependencies,
such as libraries, APIs,
or even outright
cloud platforms.
But to get around this,
we use mocking frameworks
to fake those
external dependencies.
So in general, unit tests
are useful for investigating
known problems in things
like regressions and whatnot.
However, they are not as good at
finding unanticipated problems
that come out of left field.
But they are fast to run and
rarely use build resources.
So typically because
they're self-contained,
you don't have to use any actual
Cloud resources to run them,
so they're almost
cheap or free to run.
And before we leave
this slide, there's
a diagram on the
bottom right hand,
basically this explains how
the mocking concept works.
So normally, you'd
have a feature.
And that feature calls an API,
the API returns a response,
and the feature does
something with that response.
The mocking framework
allows you to completely cut
the API out of the
conversation and say,
I'm going to return a predefined
response to the feature,
and I'm going to assert that
the feature behaves in the way
that I think it should if
the API had actually returned
that response to the feature.
That's the core idea
of unit testing.
So here, we have a sample
HTTP Google Cloud Function.
This is a pretty
straightforward function
that essentially
creates a bucket
when given a name parameter
through a POST request.
So it will take
this POST request.
It will attempt to create
the bucket on line 4,
using the
storage.createBucket function.
If that process fails, it
will send back an error
with the error message.
If it succeeds, it will
send back a success message.
So here's a sample
HTTP unit test.
You'll notice that
on line 1, we import
a bunch of different libraries.
So walking through
them, proxyquire
is a really interesting
library that, in Node.js, lets
us sort of hook into, or mock,
a client library, or rather,
a Node client library.
So in this case, we have this
google-cloud/storage client
library.
And we're replacing it,
we're hooking it over,
with a gcsMock object,
which we define on line 2.
Now, that gcsMock object is a
sort of subset of that library.
And we define a
createBucket function there
that we want to receive any
calls to storage.createBucket
in our actual code.
So instead of saying
something like,
we're going to actually
import the real library,
we import this
fake version of it,
this mock version of it
that we declared on line 2.
So once we do that, we can rely
on the library called sinon,
which gives us lots
of useful helpers
to log what kinds of arguments
are being passed to functions.
So you'll notice line 2,
we declare something called
a stub, so sinon.stub().
And the thing
about that is, that
will log any arguments
that are passed to it.
It will log how many times
it's called, things like that.
And then, we can inspect that
stub to figure out, OK, well,
how did the program
that we passed this stub
to actually use that stub?
So then, we move down
to our test on line 6.
Notice that here, we
attempt to create a bucket,
we do not actually
create a bucket.
So on line 7, we
declare our bucket name.
Lines 8 and 9, we
declare our mock versions
of request and
response parameters.
If you've worked with
Cloud Functions before
or have seen the
code previously,
you'll notice that our function
took those parameters, request
and response.
So we have to
mock, or fake, them
and pass them into our program.
So once we do that, we then
run our original function
on line 10 using the
program.createBucket call
there.
And we pass that fake
request and response object
into our program
just as if it had
been running on Cloud Functions
and received the real version
of those objects.
And then, on line 11, we check
the createBucket function,
or rather, our fake
createBucket function
with the correct argument, in
this case, the name constant.
So moving on to
integration tests,
the core idea here is to
verify that the various parts
of your code fit
together as expected.
So integration tests,
broadly speaking,
can either use mocking
or rely directly
on external dependencies.
Now, external dependencies
that they do rely on
are usually fast
and/or cheap to access,
thus keeping the individual
test runs moderately
fast, moderately quick.
But note that if you're
depending on actually billed
resources, you would have to
pay for those invocations,
you would have to
pay for those runs.
So this may require
small amounts of money
to run each iteration
of your tests.
But generally speaking, they
balance problem, detection,
and isolation.
And this is the cool part
about integration tests
is that in some cases, they
can detect unanticipated bugs.
Whereas unit tests can only
detect things that you really
specifically check
for, integration tests
have a large enough
scope that if there's
some bug that happens that you
haven't thought to check for,
there's a better probability
that integration tests
will catch it.
And just as a rough sort
of visual analog here,
where an integration
test comes in is,
let's say you have
two or more features,
an integration test
tests their ability
to sort of operate
between each other.
So if you have
three features, you
want to see how well they
talk to each other, that's
where an integration
test will come in.
And here's a sample
HTTP integration test.
You'll notice again, we
import a bunch of libraries
here, some of which are the
same, some of which are not.
Ava is our testing
harness, so that's just
a testing framework in Node.
UUID is a universal
unique identifier library,
I'll get to why that's
important later.
And then
request-promise-native is
a library that allows us to
make HTTP requests in Node.
So notice on line 2, we have
a standard Node require call.
So we are importing a live
version of the Google Cloud
Storage library.
This library, we are not
mocking this dependency,
we are importing it as-is.
Now, on line 4, we attempt
to create a real bucket.
And we do this by first
declaring a bunch of values.
In this case, we have to
declare a name for the bucket.
Note that we use
that UUID library
that I mentioned
earlier, because we
want to ensure that our bucket
names are unique whenever we're
trying to create any
actual Cloud resources.
If we don't, it's
possible that we end up
into some race condition or
something like that where
we try to create a bucket
that already exists,
or we try to delete
one that doesn't exist,
things like that.
So to avoid that, we use
that UUID function there.
Now, once we do that, we can
declare the URL of the function
we want to attempt to
send this request to.
In this case, it's
going to be a local URL.
So this BASE_URL
environment variable
is probably going
to be something
like localhost or whatever.
And then, on line 7, we
execute that HTTP request.
We say, OK, here's
our target URL,
let's pass the name to
it, so on and so forth.
Note that even when
that request returns,
the bucket itself may not
have yet been created.
So to avoid that, we have
to kind of either use
exponential back-off, which the
idea of exponential back-off
is, you wait a certain
amount of time,
then you wait that
amount of time
times 2, that amount of time
times 4, so on and so forth,
constantly multiplying
by some constant,
or perhaps even adding
some random jitter
so that if you're doing a
bunch of exponential back-off
operations, they don't
sort of all fall together.
But in this case, it's
easy and simple enough
to implement a constant delay.
And that's exactly
what we do on line 8.
So we say, we're going to wait
one second between requesting
that the bucket be created and
actually checking if it exists,
because the bucket creation
API is eventually consistent,
like a lot of Cloud APIs.
So we do that on line 10, we
check that the bucket exists.
And if it does, then
our test passes.
If it doesn't, then,
well, our function
didn't do what we wanted
to do, and our test fails.
So moving on to system tests--
and kind of as a recap, note
that system tests are all
about verifying your
code as a system.
There's a heavy reliance here
on external dependencies, which
can slow down the test itself.
And sometimes, system tests
will require moderate amounts
of build resources, because
you're directing traffic
at an actual cloud instance.
Now, system tests have
pretty good bug detection,
even if bugs are unexpected
or outside your codebase.
This is where they really
sort of show their true power.
If you're trying
to figure out, do I
have a bug in my dependencies,
or is there a bug, perhaps,
in some configuration
in my Cloud Platform?
That's where system tests will
hunt for that sort of thing.
Integration tests might
find, unit tests probably
won't find it, but system
tests have a good chance
of finding those types of bugs.
But note that they are bad at
isolating problems, generally
speaking, and their root causes,
just because system tests have
such a large scope
that they test.
One thing to take
away, and we discussed
this in the integration
tests sample as well,
is that state matters.
And it may introduce
either eventual consistency
and/or shared resource issues.
And what I mean by shared
resource issues is,
if you're trying to create a
resource that already exists
or you're trying to delete a
resource that doesn't exist,
say maybe you're running
two tests at the same time,
and they both create and
delete the same test bucket,
then it's possible that that
will introduce race conditions
or things like that that make
your test results essentially
flaky.
So here's a sample
HTTP system test.
Some of you might notice
that this looks familiar.
In fact, it's exactly the
same as the integration
test we just discussed.
The only difference is the
base URL that we specify.
So instead of being something
on our local machine,
or on, perhaps, a local
machine on the network,
it's going to be the actual
deployed Cloud Function URL.
So it's going to be
something like US, Central
1, some region, dash your
project ID @cloudfunctions.net.
Now, the thing to
bear in mind here
is the challenges of
those unique test runs,
that state dependence, and the
asynchronous nature of creating
that bucket still apply.
So those are more common
in terms of system tests.
Sometimes they happen
in integration tests,
sometimes you can mock
those dependencies out.
But in system tests,
they're almost guaranteed
to happen if you're working
with a Cloud platform.
And the one caveat that I want
to make sure I get to today
is this system test being the
same as the integration test,
this is a trope
you can typically
exploit when you're dealing
with HTTP triggered functions.
If you're dealing with something
like a PUB/SUB triggered
function, or a Firebase
triggered function,
or something like that, it's
a lot harder to just do this
and simply say, my integration
test and system test
are going to be identical.
So moving on to static
testing, so as a recap,
the goal of static testing is to
verify that your code follows,
typically, either language and
style conventions or dependency
management best practices.
Now, many of these
static testing tools
are free to install
and quick to use.
So there are two types
of static testing tools
that I want to make sure
we talk about today.
The first of which is linters.
And linters are really
useful because they enforce
style conventions on your code.
And sometimes, they
can also detect things
like interpretation
or compilation errors.
So for example,
for Node, there's
a linter tool called Prettier.
There's also a couple
of different other tools
like ESLint or Semi-Standard
that you might have heard of.
If you're a Python
developer, you probably
know about Pylint or Flake8, or
Pep8, or something like that.
And the dependency
management tools
essentially check for issues
with your dependencies.
So in Node, we have this tool
called Snyk, which effectively
checks for known insecure
versions of our dependencies
anywhere in our dependency tree.
So let's say you depend
on a package that
depends on the package
that is insecure,
Snyk will detect that and send
you an alert if you've set it
up to do so.
So the major con
of static testing
is that they have a
very narrow focus.
They're very good at
doing what they do,
but they only do a very
small amount of things.
And as an example of
why linting is useful,
you'll notice the
code on the left
is basically some JavaScript,
some contrived JavaScript,
but it's prior to linting.
And on the right,
we have that code
after we've fix the
appropriate linting errors.
So on the left, basically,
the big issue here is--
if you're not
immediately familiar
with the details
of JavaScript, it
might not be obvious
what the value of a is.
Now, someone who is, like
even a person like me who's
worked with JavaScript for
quite awhile might think, oh, a
is null, just
looking at that code.
But in fact, when you run
it, I found out, even,
that a is undefined.
So declaring it on a
separate line on the right
makes it easier for other
programmers to understand.
Now, the other thing
that the linter
flagged in our left
sample is that we
have a double equal sign there.
Now, in JavaScript, a double
equal sign essentially means,
can I cast a to b?
Not necessarily are they the
same type and the same value,
it's more, are they the same
value and can they be casted?
So we go off to the
right, we fix that,
because the linter
says, did you really
mean to just check
value equality,
or do you mean to check
type equality as well?
And in this situation, we
meant to check type equality,
so we add a third equal sign.
And then, we get that
undefined and null.
They might be the same value,
but they are not the same type.
And therefore,
they are not equal.
And you'll notice on the
left, that console.log
statement returns true.
On the right, it returns false.
So this can have an
impact in your code.
So moving on to the
idea of load testing,
so the idea of load testing is
to verify your entire system
from end to end,
including, importantly,
the non-autoscaled components'
ability to handle user demand.
So here, there is heavy reliance
on external dependencies.
And these dependencies may be
slow to access, which can slow
down the test runs themselves.
Note that a lot of
load testing tools
out there are typically free,
or at least open source.
But the test runs
themselves can require
lots of build resources, because
essentially what you're doing
is creating vast
amounts of traffic
and then directing
it at your app.
And of course, you have to
pay to process that traffic.
But load tests,
generally speaking,
help protect against sudden,
and potentially beneficial,
traffic spikes.
The example I like
to give is like,
especially if you're
in retail, there
are certain seasons of the
year, like here in the US,
it's probably like Black Friday,
where retail just suddenly
has a glut of customers.
Everyone is looking to buy
your product all of a sudden.
Or perhaps if you work
at a small startup,
and suddenly your
product gets featured
on a major internet news
site or a major newspaper,
and your user base increases
by a factor of three, or four,
or five.
So how do you test that?
If we make it big,
so to speak, how
are we going to make sure that
our site can handle that load?
Well, that's where you rely
on something like a load test.
And again, those traffic
spikes can be beneficial.
It need not be
like a distributed
denial of service or someone
trying to take down your app.
And some examples of
load testing tools--
we have Apache Bench,
which we're going
to demo on the next slide.
And that is preinstalled on
most Mac and Linux systems,
so you can just type AB on
a terminal, and it's there.
The other option is
to use Apache JMeter
if you want something
that is more configurable.
So without further ado,
we'll talk about the demo.
And you'll notice here, we
have a standard terminal.
Can anybody not see this?
Raise your hand if
you cannot see this.
Good.
So what we're going to
do-- and for good measure,
I'll make it a little larger--
so we're going to
run a command here
that does a load test for us.
So here, we're
running Apache Bench,
and notice what we're
doing here is, we're
running 50 requests total.
So we're running 50 requests
total with up to 10 requests
at once, so concurrency
of 10, to this link,
which is just a
simple HTTP Cloud
Function that I've set up.
And importantly, if we take
a look at the stats here,
we notice that all of
our requests succeeded
and none of our requests failed.
So that means that we can
count on this function
to handle the amount of load
that we've tested it to.
There's also lots of other
sort of interesting stats
here, like you can see
request percentiles,
the median request here
took 81 seconds to complete.
The longest request
took maybe 6 seconds,
which is probably due to
something like a cold start
or something like that.
And before we get going, I'm
going to execute the next step,
and we'll get to that later.
So moving on to
security testing--
so to recap, the goal
of security testing
is to verify your
code's ability to handle
malicious input, and
that of your dependencies
as well, equally importantly.
So the motivation
for security testing
is that US business has
lost $67 billion, with a B,
to cyber attacks in 2005.
That was more than 10 years ago.
So security tests can occur
anywhere in your testing stack.
They can be part of unit tests,
system tests, integration
tests, and or static tests.
Now, security testing tools
are sometimes free to install,
they're often free to install.
There are some you can purchase.
But they may cost money if
build resources are involved.
Like if you're testing your
actual Cloud deployment
and you have to pay
for that traffic,
they send potentially
malicious traffic to your Cloud
deployment, you have to
pay for that traffic.
So some examples of
security testing tools--
there's the Open Web
Application Security Project,
which is a great
resource if you're
working on web applications.
And they have something called
the Zed Attack Proxy, or ZAP,
and that is an
automated testing tool
that will go through
your website and attempt
to find security
vulnerabilities in your app.
So then, there's Snyk,
which I mentioned earlier.
It checks for known
insecure dependencies.
The Big List of Naughty
Strings, essentially it's
a list of strings that could
potentially break your app,
so things like SQL
injection, or Unicode errors,
or things like that.
And then, you have
the OSS-Fuzz tool
that I mentioned earlier,
which is written by Google.
And a couple of caveats to bear
in mind with security testing--
if you take away nothing
from the slide, this
is probably the most
important thing to take away.
So first of all, no
automated tool is perfect.
And if you're serious about
security, hire a consultant.
They will get you
closer to perfection,
but they probably won't
get you all the way.
And then, these
security testing tools
may actually damage
the environment
that they are pointed at.
Some tools are better
about this than others.
But if a tool, say,
tries to drop a database,
and you point it at your
production instance,
and it is successful,
then guess what,
you've dropped your
production database.
So when you're dealing with
security testing tools,
make sure to test them in a
test environment or something
where you're either 100%
confident that it is totally
secure, at least from that
particular security testing
tool.
Or if it gets blown
up, who cares?
Maybe you lose some test
data, but you can either
restore from a backup or--
it's the type of thing your
customers won't notice,
let me put it that way.
And here's a citation for
that stat I mentioned earlier.
So moving on to the
sort of CI/CD pipeline
and talking about how to
automate this testing process--
so the core idea here is
that for many developers,
git branches are
the source of truth.
Now, if you don't
use git, you probably
use some version control
system, whether that's
SVN, or CVS, or Mercurial,
or something like that.
But the core idea is, you think
in terms of a version control
system.
And normally, function code
must be tested and redeployed
manually.
Like in the Google
Cloud Functions context,
you have to do your
GCloud Functions deploy,
or you have to deploy it
through the UI console.
So to get around this, we can
use continuous integration
and continuous deployment
systems, or pipelines,
to automate that step.
Now, there are many different
CI/CD options available.
In the context of
this presentation,
we will use Cloud
Build, primarily
because it natively
integrates with Google Cloud
Platform and stores
repositories as well,
in our case, GitHub
and Bitbucket.
So it's actually pretty
easy to set up a basic CI/CD
for Cloud Functions.
It does take some time, it
does take some configuration.
But you could probably do
it in about half a day.
So here's an example build
configuration for Node.
This file is the
heart of Cloud Build.
This essentially
tells Cloud Build
what it needs to do to run your
tests and deploy your code.
So if you're a Node developer,
this will look pretty familiar.
If you're not, then we
can walk through it.
But essentially, what's going
on here with the first step is,
we're installing
our dependencies.
If you've worked with
Python, this will probably
look like PIP install to you.
Now, the second test
is running our tests.
If you're a Python
developer, this
will look like PyTest, or
Nox, or something like that.
But if you're a Node
developer, you use npm-test.
And the third, this
is an optional step,
but if you don't want any
sort of old zombie function
instances from your old
function lying around,
you have to go delete it.
So you can do that by doing
the GCloud functions delete
command.
Now, if you would rather have
those zombie instances around
and not risk
potentially deleting
and not being able to
deploy your function
through an automated
test, it's probably better
just to deal with the
zombie instances and just
nix this step.
But if you care more
about zombie instances
than potential failures
on the very last step,
then you probably want to
include a delete command just
to get rid of those
zombie instances.
And then, of course,
our last command
deploys our actual
function code.
And it's just a standard
GCloud functions deploy,
so on and so forth.
Now, the thing to bear
in mind is this executes
from the top down.
So if any of these steps
fail, anything below them
will not execute.
So if your tests fail, you
will not delete or deploy
the new version
of your function.
Now, if the deletion
succeeds, but the deployment
fails, like I said
earlier, you will end up
without a function deployed.
And if that is bad
for you, if that
is worse than having some
old function instances lying
around, we recommend
nixing that third step.
So now, we're going to move
to a demo of Cloud Build.
But if we move to Cloud Build
here, what we're going to do
is, we're going to make
a change to this repo.
So we're going to
execute it now.
Let's first take a look
at the commit logs here.
So we notice that we have
this commit here that says,
we're going to
change hello to hi.
And maybe our manager
comes to us and says,
I don't like this commit.
You need to get rid of it.
Remove it.
So we can do that using a--
let me check the log again,
make sure I copy the commit--
git reset, that commit, check
our status, check our log,
git reset.
Let's try this--
soft, there we go.
Whoops, that failed.
So let's try something else.
When all else fails,
nuke it from orbit.
And then, we can push
this to our master.
Maybe this is a
prod release, so we
want to make sure that
we just push it as-is.
It's pushing now.
And if we take a look
at the last commit,
we'll notice it's this
commit hash right here.
And we can go to our lovely
Container Builder, refresh it,
and we notice that we've
kicked off a build right here.
So if we go there,
we notice this
is in response to that same
git commit we just pushed.
So we can scroll down,
and we get a list of these
build steps here
as we defined them
in that cloudbuild.yaml file.
So first, we're installing
our dependencies.
Then, we're running our tests.
Then, we're deleting our old
versions of the functions,
notice the beta here,
because this command is old.
And then, we are deploying
our version of the function.
Now, if we scroll
down to our logs here,
we notice that the
build is starting.
It'll take a second or
two to kind of get going.
I'm going to zoom out a little
bit here so we can scroll here.
So it's installing
our dependencies here,
it's executing step 0.
These are just sort of
NPM prints, and NPM logs.
Then, we are running our tests
using npm run integration-test.
And then, we're starting
our quasi-emulator or shim
and trying to run our tests.
We notice our tests
are passing, 2 passed,
2 passed, scrolling
down, so all of our tests
are starting to pass here.
So all of our tests have passed.
Woo-hoo, we can now delete our
old version of the function,
and we can deploy it.
So as far as deleting it goes,
that's what we're doing here.
And it's running that
deletion operation
to delete the old
version of the function.
And then, we are deploying
the function here.
So we've already
deployed the function.
And the deployment has finished.
Now, if we go to this
URL, we'll notice
that before we had done this
commit, if I make this larger,
this used to say, "Hi World!"
And our manager came to us
and said, I don't want that.
I want it to say "Hello World!"
But if we refresh it now,
it says, "Hello World!"
as our manager asked us for.
So now that we've talked
a little bit about how
to automate that
testing process,
we can talk about what to
do when, the heavens forbid,
something goes wrong and a
bug ends up in production.
So GCF ops 101--
basically, the core idea here
is that tests can only detect
problems out of production.
So for problems in
production, we're
going to need to do
something different.
And that something
different is Stackdriver.
So Stackdriver is a set of tools
for monitoring and debugging
code on GCP.
Now, the most useful
tools for Cloud Functions
in my humble opinion are,
first of all, monitoring
and metrics, which help us
figure out whether or not
our code is broken at all, and
logging and error reporting,
which help us figure out where
and why our code is broken.
So for example, with
logging and error reporting,
these are pretty
straightforward.
Logging is kind of
a plug-and-play,
it stores and indexes
logs from your function.
Error reporting is also
fairly plug-and-play.
It's based off of
logs and it aggregates
logs into meaningful
error reports,
as you can see on the right.
So I know that the font
might be a little bit
small, so I'll try to narrate
through what's going on here.
On the left, we have a sample
log entry, which essentially
says, there is an error--
uninitialized email address.
Now, this is in some
Cloud Function called,
as we'll see on the right,
it's called onNewMessage.
So on the right, we have
stats about how frequently
this error has occurred.
It was first seen 13 days ago,
it was last seen 6 days ago,
it's occurred 152
times, we have a sample
stack trace and a histogram.
So this is a useful
command center
for triaging any errors
that you might have.
Now, as far as monitoring
and metrics go,
they are not as plug-and-play.
But they are just as,
if not more, useful
than logging and
error reporting.
So generally speaking,
Stackdriver's monitoring
and metrics tools help us
detect production bugs quickly.
They will not
necessarily guarantee
that you will detect
production bugs,
but they will increase your
chances of detecting them
in a timely manner.
So our goal with
this configuration
is to catch as many errors as
we can with the least setup
possible.
So the pros of the configuration
that we're about to talk about
are that it's easy to
set up, it determines
if production is broken, and
it can test any function type.
So the cons are that it depends
on logging statement coverage,
so basically any time
there's an error,
you need to make sure
you're logging it.
And it's not always
helpful for identifying
the root causes of
why things go wrong
or even where things go wrong.
So the sort of decent
configuration that you can use,
this is like the
first line of defense,
if you will, against
bugs in prod,
is to send out an
alert if severe log
entries, for example,
errors, are too frequent.
Maybe more than
1% of invocations
are more than some constant
or something like that.
The better option, if you
have the time and sort
of the engineer bandwidth,
is to send out an alert
if function execution time and
count exceed normal limits.
And note that when I
say better, I recommend
employing both of these.
There's no harm in having
additional metrics.
If you have to pick
one or the other,
it's probably better if
you go with the first one
than the second one.
But having both is ideal.
And some additional
checks you can do--
if you're working primarily
with HTTP-triggered functions
or, likewise,
HTTPS-triggered functions,
you can just use
Stackdriver's uptime checks
to check those URLs and make
sure those functions are
responding with
the correct status
code, so things like 200, or
302, or so on and so forth.
So without further
ado, we're going
to do a quick demo of
Stackdriver monitoring.
And notice, I kicked off
this command earlier.
Oops, it's not showing up.
But I kicked off
a command earlier
that was an Apache
Bench command that
sent 10,000 requests
to that Cloud Function
that I specified earlier.
Now, so if we look at
our Stackdriver page,
which is here--
and then we'll refresh it.
So we notice that there was
a resolved incident that
was declared today
at about 10:55 AM.
So this was an alert we got.
If we look at the
actual inbox here,
we got a Stackdriver alert.
And this was sent to
us at 10:55 today.
So it's telling us that our
metric threshold for this Cloud
Function was violated, and
it's above our threshold of 5
with a value of 37.383.
So what this is telling us
is, you said, send me an alert
if more than 5 executions
were happening concurrently.
We had 37.
So if you got
something like this,
you'd probably want to
say, OK, well, what's
going wrong with this function?
Is it just suddenly
super popular?
It some retry loop?
Is some API calling
it way too many times?
What's going on here?
And of course, once
you get this email,
then you can follow up and
investigate as appropriate.
So now that we've talked
about all this stuff,
we can kind of recap
what we've learned today.
So as kind of a background of
how all this works, or rather,
we've given a background
of how all this works
and talked about an overview of
testing strategies in general.
Then, we talked a little
bit about applying that
to the world of serverless.
Finally, we talked
about CI/CD pipelines,
how to automate this
testing on an ongoing basis.
And then, a little
bit about what
to do when, despite
our best efforts,
a bug gets out of our canary or
whatever and into production,
and we need to do
something to detect
that bug quickly and resolve
it, ideally before our customers
notice.
So the key points that I
would like people to take away
from this presentation-- if
there's a side where you want
to take a photo, this is it.
So narrating through
this, basically testing
helps detect bugs and other
issues on an ongoing basis.
So testing is effectively
an insurance policy
against potential bugs.
And if your managers ever
ask, well, why should
we write tests?
The answer is, they not only
stop those potential bugs,
but they stop the business
impact of those potential bugs.
Note that, also, there are
many testing options out there
that we reviewed-- unit
tests, function tests,
system tests, so
on, and so forth,
or integration tests, system
tests, so on, and so forth.
And they all have
different trade-offs
in terms of accuracy,
breadth, speed, and cost.
Generally speaking, we recommend
that on critical, reused,
or unmaintained
code, you have lots
of tests with a variety
of different scopes.
So you're going to have
a lot of unit tests,
you're going to have
a lot of system tests,
you're going have a lot of
integration tests, maybe
several static tests,
so on, and so forth.
On less important, temporary,
or well-maintained code,
you can usually get away with
fewer higher-level tests.
Because generally speaking, if
your code is well-maintained
and you know there's a bug,
you can go in and triage it
pretty quickly.
But if you don't
know there's a bug,
then there's a
problem, because if you
don't know that the problem
exists, you can't address it.
So that's why those higher-level
tests are important to say,
well, does my code work at all?
And if my code works
from end to end,
then I'm reasonably
confident that there
isn't going to be a bug in it.
But if the system tests
fail, then you can say,
OK, well something's broken.
I don't know what,
but at least I
can go deeper, and
take a look at it,
and figure out what went wrong.
Now, the third takeaway
here is that Stackdriver
increases your
chances of detecting
production bugs quickly.
Emphasis on increases
your chances,
there is no guarantee
you will detect them
within a certain amount of time.
But it's easier to detect
them and more likely
that you will detect them
if Stackdriver is present.
The broad configuration is to
check for abnormal error rates
and execution times.
It's pretty easy
to set up again,
like it would probably
take a developer maybe
about an hour or two, at most.
And finally, note that tests
must address Cloud-specific
challenges.
So the challenge of
eventual consistency,
you can address that using
either timeouts or exponential
back off.
And then the challenge
of shared resources,
you can address this by using
temporary test environments
or temporary test resources like
we did with that UUID function
in the system test example.
So I'd like to thank you for
coming to Next today and coming
to my talk.
If you have any questions,
feel free to email me
at faast@google.com.
That is the word
faast, with two As.
Otherwise, I'll be hanging
around the serverless demo
both.
So you're welcome to come
and speak to me there.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]